découvrez-en icinéma kidnappe à ton tour
chucho
marco voulons
au japon produit
est ce que quelqu'un a vu un petit
garçon avec les cheveux frisés
à
[Musique]
décembre et monfils mais des mois
mon fils a été kidnappé j'ai lancé un
avis de recherche ne vous n'avez plus
qu'à attendre
c'est ce qu'ont fait tous ces chats ils
ont attendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au mondial
je vous préviens
aussi longtemps que mon petit garçon
sera dans cette voiture
vous pouvez être certain que
j'arrêterais pas vous suivrai au vous
allez je vous promets que je vous
laisserai jamais
vous savez kidnappé le mauvais canard
qui dope le 14 septembre sur au service
de vidéo à la demande
exclusivement chez fo